is this a hot dog or not a hot dog what
about this one
in this course you will learn about
convolutional neural networks these are
a class of deep learning neural networks
that are particularly effective for
classifying images
cnns are also used for other
applications such as natural language
processing and time series forecasting
but they're most commonly associated
with image processing Kylie Ying teaches
this course Kylie is a sophomore and she
is passionate about machine learning and
artificial intelligence so let's start
learning after you determine if this is
a hot dog
welcome to this introductory course on
convolutional neural networks in this
course I'm going to be talking about how
our computer can look at an image with a
dog in it and say hey this is a dog
so the secret behind that is exactly
this convolutional neural networks and
that's what we're going to be discussing
today
from me looking at this clearly this is
a hot dog
I don't think that's a hot dog can't
really tell what that is hummus hot dog
garlic bread hot dog hot dog oysters and
it looks like sausage and waffle
and now if we look at our labels one
means that our model thinks it's a hot
dog zero means that it doesn't think
it's a hot dog so for the first row we
get yes no no so we get hot dog not a
hot dog not a hot dog and then we get
yes no yes so hot dog not a hot dog hot
dog and then yes no no so hot dog not a
hot dog not a hot dog and I think that's
pretty awesome for a model that we are
going to learn in this video today
it's ready
please God what do we say if I told you
there is an app on the mind we're past
that part just demo it
okay let's start with a hot dog
[Music]
oh yeah
my beautiful little Asiatic friend I'm
going to buy you the Palapa of your life
we will have 12 posts braided Palm
leaves you'll never feel exposed again
I'm Gonna Be Rich do pizza let's do
pizza yeah okay
Hey sir
[Music]
not hot dog
wait what
that's that's it it only does hot dogs
no and a not hot dog
if you guys have already seen a few of
my previous
Camp machine
skip ahead to the section that actually
discusses convolutional neural networks
and then the collab where we will be
practicing how to actually implement
this on a very exciting project okay for
those of you who are new here stay tuned
we're going to cover the basics of
machine learning and we will build up to
understanding how a convolutional neural
network works all right so let's get
started this is the introduction to
convolutional neural networks presented
by me Kylie Ying on behalf of free code
Camp make sure you guys go and check out
my channel Kylie Ying for beginner
programming content as well as future
courses on artificial intelligence so
with that being said let's Dive Right In
what exactly is machine learning
well Machine learning is a subdomain of
computer science that focuses on
algorithms which help a computer learn
from data without us programmers
explicitly programming certain
instructions so basically we want to be
able to train our computer to understand
or to comprehend or to draw some sort of
conclusion to learn from certain data
that we feed it
so there's a few different types of
machine learning the first type is known
as supervised learning
in supervised learning we use labeled
inputs which means that each input has a
corresponding output label to train
models and to learn outputs so let's
look at some examples basically here we
have a few pictures right we have a
picture of a cat we have a picture of a
dog and we have a picture of this looks
like a gecko
now our computer doesn't actually know
these labels ahead of time so we as
humans have labeled these items and we
are familiar with pictures of cats dogs
and geckos so we can label these in our
head but our computer only sees pixels
and so what we are doing in supervised
learning
is we are actually constructing a data
set with these labels attached to them
so when we feed these pictures to our
computer we're saying hey this top left
one is a cat this right one is a dog and
this bottom one okay I labeled it as a
lizard but you get the point basically
we're feeding it a label when we pass it
into the computer
now there's also unsupervised learning
and basically this uses unlabeled data
to learn about patterns in data so here
if we have these images well you know if
we have multiple different images of
cats multiple different ones of lizards
geckos these things and then multiple
pictures of dogs then our goal is our
computer would be able to learn from all
of these and be able to pull out similar
features and say Hey you know these all
seem like they're one type of category
this seems like another category and
this seems like it'd be another category
so that's unsupervised learning where we
don't necessarily provide the labels and
our computer is trying to draw
conclusions from similarities that it
finds in our data set
now the last type of machine learning is
known as reinforcement learning so in
reinforcement learning there's an agent
that's learning in an interactive
environment and it learns based on
Rewards or penalties that it observes
while it does some sort of action
throughout this environment
so for example training your dog is a
type of reinforcement learning and we're
essentially replacing this dog with a
computer
so when we train our dogs you know if
our dog sits then we feed it a treat and
if our dog barks we might yell at it and
get angry and the dog will eventually
hopefully
stop barking sometimes my dog is not
like that but anyways based on these
rewards and penalties the dog basically
picks up intuition about what actions
will be able to get future rewards and
what actions will lead to Future
penalties so that's reinforcement
learning we train our computer in a very
similar way but our reward for our
computer might just be something like
points
today we are focusing on supervised
learning
so let's talk about supervised learning
a bit more
basically in machine learning we have
some sort of inputs so here we have
inputs one through n so these are all of
our samples all of our examples and they
go into some model which we'll talk
about in a second and then it leads to
some sort of output some sort of
prediction
now
the terminology here is that all of our
inputs these are known as our feature
vectors so each input that we give our
model should be in the form of some sort
of parsable data which often means just
a vector of numbers
now these features can be qualitative so
that typically means categorical data
there are finite numbers of categories
or groups so one example of that might
be
the traditional way of defining gender
so female or male this is qualitative
because there's only a certain number of
groups another example might be okay
what country do you live in well there
are only a finite number of countries
out there and so this is qualitative
data this is categorical there's a
finite number of categories
so this is known as nominal data because
there is no inherent order it's not like
a happiness rating where you know zero
is unhappy and five is very happy
there's no ranking between either of
these now the other type of qualitative
data might be something like age
right so these are different categories
of being you know an infant and then a
child and then a teenager an adult
Etc and as I just said there might also
be happiness rankings so you know one
two three four five five being really
happy one being not that happy and this
is known as ordinal data because there's
an inherent ordering to this data set
but basically both of these are known as
qualitative data sets because they are
like categorical there's only a certain
number of categories there and now you
might be wondering okay doesn't that
Encompass all of our data no so the
other type of data is quantitative data
so that means it might be numerical
value data and it could be discrete or
continuous so some examples of that are
okay how long is something you get a
number right like my death could be
5.289 feet long
sorry if you don't use the American
measurement system which is the rest of
the world but you've got my point it's
an infinite length it's a numerical
system now it can also be temperature so
for example this might be
I don't know 200 degrees Fahrenheit
again sorry if you do not use Fahrenheit
which happens to be everybody not in
America
or it could even be a discrete numerical
value so for example if we're on an
Easter egg hunt well it looks like we
have something around like maybe 10 or
so eggs in our basket so that number
might be 10 but that could be zero all
the way to
Infinity right the basic point of this
is that it's quantitative so it's
numerical data and these two values are
continuous because you could have like
pie feet right but you can't really have
pie eggs so that's why this is discrete
it means that it only follows like one
two three like counting numbers
whereas continuous does it
okay so those are our features and so
now let's talk about the types of
predictions the outputs of our model
so the different types of outputs that
we can have the first type of task is
called classification and this means
we're going to go and predict discrete
classes
so for example if we have a picture of a
hot dog a pizza and an ice cream cone
classification would say okay this is a
hot dog this is a pizza and this is an
ice cream cone it'd give us three
distinct categories and try to map
something into one of those categories
this is known as multi-class
classification because we have more than
two types of classes now if I were to
classify these into hot dog and then not
hot dog then that becomes binary
classification because there's only two
options so it's one or the other
multi-class is more than two so I could
have like 10 different types of food and
try to classify into these 10 different
types
other examples of classification so
binary classification you'd have like
positive or negative sentiment in a
paragraph or a picture might be a cat or
a dog or you know an email might be
classified as spam or not spam for
multi-class you might have cat dog
lizard dolphin Etc all the animals in
the animal kingdom you might have orange
apple pear or you might have all the
different species of plants in the world
now the second type of supervised
learning is known as regression so in
this case we're trying to predict a
continuous value so here we might be
trying to predict the price of an asset
such as I think I took this a screenshot
from like ethereum or something but we
might be trying to predict the price of
ethereum or we might be trying to
predict how much snowfall we're going to
have on some certain day or we might be
trying to predict the housing market how
much will this house cost you know in
two months or two years or 20 years so
these are all regression tasks because
we're trying to predict continuous
values now let's dive a little bit into
the model before we talk about the
different types of models let's kind of
discuss how do we actually make this
model learn how can we tell whether or
not it's actually learning
let's talk about that
so let's take this data set for example
this data set is a data set that I found
online it is a Pima Indian diabetes data
set and this was originally provided by
the National Institute of diabetes and
digestive and kidney diseases let's talk
a little bit about what we're actually
looking at so here we have the labels
for the different columns right so
number of pregnancies glucose levels
blood blood pressure skin thickness
insulin BMI age and then outcome whether
or not they have diabetes
each row here represents a different
sample in the data set so each
individual that this data was collected
from that's what each row represents
right so this individual here had one
pregnancy and these were her glucose
values blood pressure skin thickness
insulin BMI age and then the outcome
whether or not this person has diabetes
and this row down here might tell a
different story it might be a different
person well it is a different person
now each column well this is a different
feature so this specific feature is the
blood sugar or sorry blood pressure
feature
so this measures all the blood pressure
levels amongst our entire data set
except for this one over here this is
our outcome so this is our output label
and here specifically our output label
is ones and zeros because we need to
transform yes and no into a language
that our computer can understand our
computer is very very good with numbers
so in this specific example we're coming
up with zero being negative no diabetes
and then one being positive which stands
for they have diabetes and this is a
very very common way of actually
encoding yes or no for our labels
or actually for even our features as
well but anyways this is our output
label
everything all of our features minus our
output label this is what we would call
a feature Vector now this is what gets
passed into our model
and then this over here this is what we
call the target for the feature Vector
so essentially if I pass my model these
values then I would want it to get as
close to the Target or the actual value
because remember we're doing supervised
learning we would want these values to
get as close to this target as possible
and same with any of these other samples
if I pass this value into our model I
would hope that it predicts zero if I
pass in this row this feature Vector in
I would want it to predict one
and when we put all of these feature
vectors together we call this the
features Matrix X and this is only
really important when you know you might
be studying a bit of linear algebra if
you go on into more in-depth machine
learning
and this over here this is our labels or
our targets Vector also known as y so
again this is just something a little
bit of terminology so let's actually
visualize this as a chocolate bar so
here we have this x Matrix
which has all of our future vectors so
imagine like a row of chocolate is a
feature vector
and these are all of our targets the
corresponding targets for each of those
feature vectors all right if I take a
feature Vector from my data set and I
pass it into this model well my model is
going to Output some sort of prediction
right now how do we use our actual
output label in order to help us you
know determine a better model so what I
can actually do is I can take the output
the actual value the actual outcome
because we have that information since
this is supervised learning and I'm
going to compare my
prediction with the actual output given
to us in our original data set
now what I can do is I can take you know
some sort of difference between these
two say okay how far am I from this
desired output I'm going to use that
data and I'm going to train the model
using that now if we're inputting many
different vectors into our model getting
the outputs of those taking the
difference and training our model then
our model over time as we train it will
get closer and closer to predicting you
know the actual output
down here
so this is our supervised learning data
set it's this chocolate bar with
over here our features vector and then
our
our output labels
what we normally do is we actually split
it up into three different types of data
sets so we have this like training data
set which will be most of our data we
use our data in order to train our model
but now how do we actually determine how
good does our model predict on stuff it
hasn't seen yet because what we would
ideally want to do is
take it out into the real world someday
right and say hey here's a picture
what's in this so in order to do that we
also need a testing data set so that
testing data set is just some data that
we've removed from our original data set
and we're just going to use that in
order to see how well our model can do
on data that it hasn't seen yet so it's
part of our original data but we're
removing it holding it off to the side
so that when we finish our model we can
say hey now look at this new data how
well how well can you perform on this
okay so what exactly is this validation
data set here in the middle okay so when
you're actually building the model
suppose that you have a bunch of
different models that you've come up
with how do you actually choose which
one is the best that's where the
validation data set comes in so imagine
you are out buying a car right there's
many different types of cars some of
them are just slightly better than the
other some of them just have a few
things here and there changed just like
small bells and whistles right so this
is a test drive where you're going
You're testing out all the models and
you're picking out okay this one is the
best and this is the one that I want to
keep
now what's the difference between
validation and testing well validation
is used on all the models so you can
pick out the best one and then testing
you're using that model and you're
saying okay well how well does this
model do on data that I haven't seen yet
and these two we both keep aside so like
they're not used for training but they
have two different purposes
so remember that validation is test
driving picking out the best model
testing data set is used on that best
model in order to get your final
accuracy number or final metric about
how well your model does
okay so let's visualize each of those
this training data set is passing the
model and the model produces some sort
of prediction for each of the feature
vectors in this training data set
so this training data makes some sort of
prediction and we're actually comparing
it to the actual output
and when we take the difference
comparing the two outputs that is what's
known as the loss now this loss can be
used to actually make adjustments which
is known as training to this model
now this validation set again is used as
a reality check during and after
training to first of all ensure that the
model can handle unseen data
and then also to say okay which model do
we want to use so again this is a test
drive here we have Model A has a loss of
1.3 model B has a loss of 1.5 model C
has a loss of 0.5 and Model D has a loss
of 0.9 so which one is the best model
it's model C
now finally once we've selected model C
we take our test set we pass it through
model C and we get our final performance
between these two our output and our
actual label and our test set is used to
check how generalizable the final chosen
model is so that means how well can our
final model perform on data it hasn't
seen yet
all right let's talk about this loss
function loss is basically a metric of
performance it tells our computer hey
this is how well we're doing right now
and so if our prediction is further from
the output the greater the loss will be
so for example this pink one
it's a slightly higher loss than that
brown because it's further from that
chocolate bar
right or if we have this blue then
that's really far from the chocolate bar
and we have a lot of correcting to do in
our model so these are what's known as
loss functions so for L1 loss basically
we have this absolute value shape and L2
loss we have this quadratic shape let's
talk a little bit about what these
actually mean so here the X
axis is the difference between the
predicted and the actual value so if we
go back to you know these
this is talking about how far apart are
these values
so
the further from zero these are the more
different they are right and Y over here
this is the penalty so this is how much
are we getting like penalized for being
further away from our actual value and
you'll notice if you look at the scales
here L1 is linear
right so that means that if I'm like 10
away from my actual value then my
penalty will just be 10.
what this L2 loss on the other hand is
quadratic so that means if I'm 10 away
then I'm actually penalizing by a
hundred right so that's
I mean that's that's literally x squared
now that also means that the closer I am
so within one away this absolute value
of one away from the actual value then
my loss is going to be less penalty than
L1
but anyways what I wanted to clarify
here let's not get too deep into the
math is just that there's two different
types of loss functions which will tell
our computer hey this is how far off we
are
there's also this thing known as binary
cross entropy loss so this is for binary
classification oh yeah I should clarify
that these L1 L2 losses are for
regression so that's when we're trying
to predict a final output and we're
telling our computer hey we're kind of
far from that output
now binary cross entropy loss is when we
have binary classification so we have
two different categories that we're
trying to classify and we're not going
to try and understand this equation but
what we do want to take away from this
is that as the loss decreases the
performance will get better as our model
does better at predicting the right
output this loss decreases
okay so metrics a performance that we
can assess that will tell us how good
our model is performing the first one is
accuracy
so for example over here I have a bunch
of different fruits right I have apple
orange Apple Apple
and our labels are over here so our
actual labels are Apple orange Apple
Apple
now let's say that these get passed into
our model
well our model comes up with these
predictions Apple orange orange Apple
so what is the accuracy of our model
here
the accuracy of this model is three
quarters it's 75 percent because we've
gotten three of the four correct and
generally for now for this introduction
we will be only sticking to accuracy in
order to talk about how well our model
is performing
finally let's talk about the model
itself in this video I'm going to focus
on neural Nets just because it's a very
common example and very powerful example
of a model but there's many many
different models out there
so neural networks looks something like
this we have our inputs and so these are
all of our features
I know that I showed you guys previously
with the feature Vector horizontal but
now let's take that horizontal and let's
turn it so it's vertical so if we have
you know some sort of age
um
glucose level I forgot what the Pima
Indians data set was but if we have like
age glucose pregnancies then now it's
going to be age glucose pregnancies okay
and this is going to be our feature
Vector it's going to be this way
these values will get passed into these
hidden nodes
and what does that mean we will dive
into nodes just in a second and these
outputs of these cells will get passed
into an output and this output these
output cells will determine what the
final output of this neural network
looks like
so as promised let's take a look at
these specific nodes
okay so again here I have my feature
Vector but vertical instead of
horizontal so this is x0 X1 all the way
until n so basically we have
n and then plus one more but n plus one
different features over here okay
now all of these different values
they all get some sort of weight
attached to them
so that might mean okay we want to
emphasize x0 some more so let's double
the value of that so this weight might
be two or hey we don't really like you
know X1 doesn't seem that important
let's decrease the significance of that
this weight might be 0.5 okay so
essentially we're multiplying this W
with this X
and now the value the output of that
goes into this neuron and this neuron is
just taking all of these like products
and summing them together
on top of that it gets something called
a bias which you can think of as like an
x-intercept basically this is just
saying Okay add this specific number
whatever this number represents add this
number to the neuron
and then finally the output of the sum
of all of these plus this one gets
passed into something known as an
activation function
and that activation function then
whatever output of that that is the
output of a single node in our neural
net
okay and then you have all these nodes
you can chain them together so I know
that I use circles to represent this but
this entire thing is basically
encapsulated in its own Circle so that
represents like this entire circle
contains this entire thing right so each
of these circles has their own outputs
that go into different nodes that you
know it's doing the same thing it's
taking the product then the summation
and then that gets output into like some
sort of output layer and here this is
the final output of the neural network
I kind of glossed over this activation
function so let's go a little bit deeper
into that let's talk about that
okay so the activation function if all
of these were just a product and a sum
and a little bit of something added then
we get an output that's just a summation
of products right and when we chain all
those together
so without activation functions this
basically this entire thing just
collapses into a linear model and by
linear model what I mean from that is
just we could have one coefficient per
input so we multiply those two together
and then we add a bias and that would be
our output it would be essentially if
all of this entire network could
collapse into one cell which if we don't
have activation functions that's kind of
what happens
so we do need activation functions now
what are they
okay these are three examples of
different types of activation functions
that we can use so this is a sigmoid
function this is a tangent function and
this is a relu function rectified linear
unit or something like that I can't
remember what this stands for what this
actually means over here it just means
okay what is the output of the cell the
y-axis here is the output so whatever
you know
this output here
is this y-axis over here
and with sigmoid essentially what we're
doing is we're taking the product and
the summation of all the products so all
the different things that come into this
neuron here so all of this stuff that
gets
summed up
whatever the value of that is is this
x-axis down here okay so actually with
all of them
whatever that value is becomes the
x-axis and we just want to map that
to whatever the Y value is and that will
be the Y output of a single cell
and again the reason why we use these
activation functions is so that we
create some sort of non-linear we
introduced some sort of non-linear value
into our neural net so that it doesn't
all collapse into a linear function
so that's the importance of activation
functions typically I will use relu
because that is just a very classic
activation function that is known to
work
all right now how does this part the
training actually work with a neural net
let's talk about that box for a bit
okay suppose that we're using our L2
loss function okay so again that's this
quadratic value and remember that these
X axes are how far is our predicted
value from our actual value how far is
that we can calculate a numerical
distance for that
then this y value is okay here's the
penalty for being that far away now if
you're really really close together then
that penalty is going to be really small
but if you're like pretty far that
penalty is going to be even larger
so up here
the error is really large
and our goal is to decrease this loss so
our goal is to get somewhere down here
right like ideally zero because that
would mean that we have a perfect
prediction but we want to get just close
enough
now that means that we have to take the
giant step in this direction in order
to get to that value and in order to do
that we can use something called
gradient descent which is a heavy
mathematics concept that will also
include some calculus so we're not going
to cover that in the scope of this
course but let's kind of just get a
general sense for what gradient descent
means
basically our gradient set means okay
this is where we are and so what is like
the slope at this point so at this point
the slope looks something like this down
here the slope looks something like this
and down here the slope looks something
like this so basically just means like
at your specific point how much are you
changing so that's your slope okay so
now once we have that value for the
slope gradient descent is saying okay
well let's follow that slope down
because we want to minimize our value
right so we're just going to follow
gradient descent down towards wherever
it's going
so if we take a look at these different
like w values because these are the ones
that we can adjust in order to train our
neural net so these remember are what
we're multiplying with our inputs in
order to get that summed output which
then goes into the activation function
so we're taking a look at our W's which
are our weights and maybe you know with
our current model
with this weight
it's super far off from where we want it
to be and so what we can do is we can
calculate this
like trajectory and we can say oh we
want to take a step this way now in W1
we might be slightly closer and we want
to take a smaller step in this direction
and finally you know another one of the
random weights might be even closer and
so then we only take a smaller step in
this direction
but essentially what back propagation
does what this gradient descent does is
it's telling us okay we want to take a
step in this direction in order to
correct our weight how much of an
adjustment do I make and in what
direction
now in order to get that new weight I'm
taking the old weight and then I'm just
tacking on some Alpha so just some like
very small value that's what Alpha
represents some very small value we call
that the learning rate but some very
small value times
this step
okay so basically our new value will be
this old one and then adjusted slightly
by this
and this as I mentioned is called The
Learning rate this is typically a really
small value and it's just to make sure
we don't like overshoot
and so with all of these different
weights
we can take this value and we can
multiply it by our learning rate and
then calculate out this new value based
on the old one and you'll see that this
magnitude of this Vector is smaller
than the one over here which means that
we're going to make a smaller step
and if you want to get really technical
then sometimes you'll see this as
negative Alpha times the slope and
that's only because or like the
derivative that's only because here I'm
I'm don't get too caught up in that the
whole point is we want to take a step
down towards our goal down here
and here I've already flipped the sides
so that's why there's a positive if
you're wondering
if you had no idea what I just said
don't worry about it just get the
general idea of this and this is how
like training neural networks we adjust
our weights based on how far we are from
where we want to be okay so the moment
we've all been waiting for let's talk
about convolutional neural networks
otherwise known as cnns
so here we have this handwriting
in an image
and the whole goal of our let's say that
okay so let's say that we are building a
model to detect what number in
handwriting is written in an image so
here we have an image where to us our
human eye we say okay I think that's a
five right but our computer doesn't know
that how do we get our computer to
determine that using supervised learning
so that's where CNN's convolutional
neural nets come in
we want to somehow pass this image into
a neural network what we just talked
about in order to produce some sort of
output prediction for the number that's
actually in this image
well
this image doesn't really translate into
a neural net too well right because
think about the Pima Indians data set we
had different values in each column
which means that every single sample so
this here this five would be technically
one sample every single thing in our
data set had like
this very nice Vector of values to
associate with it but here in our image
we don't really have that nice Vector
right it doesn't really pass into this
neural network too well so how do we
solve that
and the answer is using convolutional
neural networks
so this area here which we'll talk about
this is our convolution part but
essentially what we're doing here is
we're trying to extract features
what that means is that we're doing all
these operations so that we can get this
input boil it down to a vector that's
easily passed into a neural net that can
actually perform the classification so
all of this that we're going to learn in
convolutional neural network is just
tacked onto the beginning of a neural
net so we can take an image as is pass
it through all these different layers so
we can finally produce an output Vector
for that
input and then pass it through the
convolutional neural network
okay so something to notice is that
images are actually numbers so here I
have an image of this X and you'll see
that certain pixels are darker than the
others but our images are composed of
arrays of pixels so basically we have
this like 2D Matrix right and each
Matrix each cell has some number
associated with it
the darker it is the closer to zero it
is and the lighter it is the closer to
255 it is so white is 255 and 0 is black
and now you know something that's gray
might be in the 100s
but essentially this maps to this over
here
and now once we have this 2D array we're
going to pass something called a
convolution over it
so a convolution uh by definition is a
mathematical operation on two functions
that produces a third function
what that means in our image processing
world is that okay here we have some
sort of input 2D array which represents
our image right because our image again
is this 2D array
we have this 2D array and then we have
some sort of filter on that 2D array
right so this filter is going to take
these cells in its size so like this
filter is three by three so it's going
to take cells in a three by three grid
on this input map it's going to do some
sort of operation most likely summing up
everything
and then mapping it to something on an
output map so it might take like so
basically what you're going to do is
take this thing and keep sliding it over
every single possible 3x3 window on our
input project that onto this output
and that's a convolution so here's a
little example okay so this is our
filter
and we're just going to Overlay this on
each part of the Matrix these values are
just extensions of this because we don't
have anything to fill it but we're just
going to keep sliding it over summing
all of these up you can see the
summation calculation down here
projecting it onto this output Matrix
over here
so we do that for all the different rows
and then we finally get this value this
output value based on this convolution
now there's many different types of
things that can come out of this filter
also known as a kernel
so here's one example this is some sort
of edge detection on this original input
so this Edge detection will give us all
the edges in the image that is the
convolutional layer of a convolutional
neural net basically what we're doing is
we're taking our image we're trying to
toggle these filters so that they're
able to extract some sort of meaningful
information from our original images so
like here these are edges but like in
some cases might be looking for eyes in
the image right and it's going to take
it's going to make a filter in order to
detect these objects and map it onto an
output image so that's a convolution and
in our convolutional neural net we're
essentially training that filter to be
able to detect these important
properties
now another important concept is pooling
so if we go back to our CNN image you'll
see that we have all these convolutions
and then we pool them so what does this
pooling mean
okay so pooling is essentially taking a
larger input and reducing it down to
something smaller that might still
represent the data in that original
output
so if we use two by two pooling
basically what that's doing is it's
taking the two by two cell and the
original input taking the largest
because this is Max pooling it's taking
the largest value in these four cells
and projecting it down here over here
184 so it's 184 and this two by two
array it's 12 so 12 and then over here
it's 45 so it's 45 down here there's
also a different type of pooling called
average pooling which instead of taking
the maximum we'll just take the average
of the four values in the cell and
project that
so what you need to know from pooling is
just we're taking a larger array we're
condensing that information down into a
smaller more compact array
and so then we put those two together
and that becomes our CNN
often we usually have more convolutional
and pooling layers and then we also have
more fully connected layers but this is
a good schematic of what's going on this
is a visualization that I got from this
website I will post these slides and the
site in the description
um but essentially here it's really cool
because what I did was I essentially
Drew this five
and this is a first convolution this is
what happens after the first convolution
essentially it's taking this five and
projecting it towards many different
onto you know different kernels and such
and then it's taking these and pulling
these
it's doing another convolution on these
pooled layers
and then pulling those once more
flattening it into some sort of you know
linear thing that we can put into a
neural network
that goes into this neural network
and then the output of all of these
cells will tell us what value it
actually thinks it is so let's click on
that link this is something of what it
looks like if I draw a one
you'll see that the first guess is one
and the second guess is zero
and
each one of these cells on here is taken
from something down here so like this
specific cell
is the output of these cells over here
okay so all of these are some sort of
filter
so it actually shows you the filter if I
click on it so it takes the input image
performs some sort of filter on that
area and then gets this value so here
our input well we see this like grid and
we see these two blue cells in our input
and the filter we use that filter in
order to get this blue cell over here
and you'll see that
these are the pulling layers so it takes
multiple cells and then pulls them down
to only like to a smaller array and then
we perform some sort of convolution on
these and this might be the input of
multiple different images so like here
we're taking four images and we're
getting this cell over here right so we
have all these inputs and these are the
filters on all of those
and it gets some sort of output based on
that
whereas here you know our inputs our
filters
you get the point but basically it's
like it's just taking all these inputs
putting some sort of filter on it so
we're summing up all these different
things and then we have some sort so
they're using a tant function for their
um for their non-linearity that
activation function that we talked about
and finally this like all of these again
pooling each of these cells is some sort
of value from derived from all of these
pooled values
and then finally this is our fully
connected neural net
and then there's an output layer which
is over here so this is our output and
over here it's saying the one is lit up
saying hey we think that this is a
maximum value which means that this is
what we think is our prediction you'll
see that zero
is negative 0.96 7 is negative 0.99 well
we think that this one
is the max
so play around with this this is a
really cool uh let's do like a four
okay so our first guess is four so I
guess is one and you'll see that floor
four over here is lit up
the big picture here is that we're
taking this uh
input we're projecting it multiple times
we're doing some sort of like filter
over each like grid mini Grid in this
original input and we're just doing a
bunch of like array filtering mechanisms
basically putting that into a this layer
here which is essentially our feature
Vector for this image
and then putting that through a neural
network in order to get our prediction
okay so
we don't actually have to code all of
that we just kind of have to have this
understanding of how it works because
the beauty of machine learning is that
there are machine learning libraries
where we can actually Implement our
models
so what that means is that we have this
model that we want to implement in
machine learning and it might look
something like this but what we can do
is we can replace it with something that
has already encoded all the different
like mathematics Concepts behind each of
these layers
and we can simply say okay it's a
sequential model with you know two fully
connected layers of 16 units using relu
activations and then we have this output
and that is the beauty of tensorflow so
tensorflow is an open source library
that helps us develop and train machine
learning models and in this next example
let's actually take a look at how we can
use tensorflow and train a convolutional
neural network on different images of
food in order to produce predictions of
whether or not a food is a hot dog now
that we've learned about the basics of
machine learning neural networks and
cnns let's actually look at an example
and see how we can use tensorflow in
order to build a model train a data set
and use this model to actually evaluate
outputs okay so I'm going to go to
collab.research.google.com and I'm going
to start a new notebook
and this notebook I'm going to title
hot dog versus
not hot dog
example because today what we're going
to be classifying is pictures of food
and we're going to be labeling them as
hot dogs or not hot dogs so let's dive
into this
all right the first thing that we want
to do is import a few different
libraries so we can import numpy as NP
import pandas as PD
import
lib dot Pi plot as PLT
uh let's import random
we can import
oops
import tensorflow as TF and from
tensorflow
doc Harris we're going to import data
sets layers and models
and then finally we're going to actually
get our data from tensorflow
underscore data sets and we're going to
import that as tfds
so basically these are some data
analysis tools that we have PLT is a
plotting tool this is just the random
Library so if you need a random number
generator or something tensorflow
um that should be Keras
this is more tensorflow stuff and then
this is finally the data set that we'll
be looking at
so go ahead and run that cell you can
run it by clicking this play button or
you can use shift enter and that will
run a cell so in this video today we're
going to be building a hot dog versus
not hot dog classification model using
tensorflow to distinguish hot dogs from
not hot dogs in food images all right so
now I'm going to add a citation and you
don't have to worry about this but this
is just so that we can give credit to
the people who actually produce this
this data set that is all right so let's
talk about the data really quickly so
tensorflow already has the food 101 data
set so we'll actually use that and you
can learn more about that by clicking
this link here now in this data set the
hot dog label is label number 55. so
let's take a look at this data set
itself
okay so the first thing that we need to
do is actually import this data and we
can do that by using tfds so that again
is our tensorflow data sets over here
so if we do this dot load and then we
use the string food 101 then that
actually tensorflow will load the food
101 data set and we're going to shuffle
the files
um
and because we want this as a supervised
data set we're going to set this to true
and we'll just also include info in that
as well and here we this will actually
return a tuple with the data set as well
as the data set info because we have
chosen to include that over here
all right so we're going to run this
cell and this cell will actually take a
little while to run so we'll just sit
here and wait and you can pause the
video until that cell finishes running
all right so finally our data set is
loaded so the first thing we're going to
do is actually split up the data set
into train and validation sets
so here I'm going to get a trained data
set and a validation data set
and this is because this data set
automatically comes with train and
validation
data sets
split up
so
I'm gonna grab those and then let's
actually show some examples so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to use csds dot
show
underscore examples
and what I'm going to do is actually
pass in the train data set and then the
data set info which contains all the
different information
so if I hit enter there
we get you know Pizza chocolate cake
bruschetta waffles Etc and somewhere in
there is hot dog and actually hot dog
the label for that is number 55. I found
that I think by just
running this a bunch of times and seeing
where hot dogs came up one thing that
you might notice here is that these
images are all different sizes right
they're not all square so the first
thing we want to do is actually we want
to resize it and then the second thing
you might notice that we have a bunch of
different labels right but what we're
interested in is hot dog versus not hot
dog
so what I'm actually going to do is I'm
going to take an image actually let's
use this one this chocolate cake image
over here I'm going to resize it so that
it's 128 by 128. and then pixels and
then I'm going to cast the label such
that it either equals a hot dog so
that's one or it doesn't so that's zero
okay so the maximum side length that I
want here is going to be 128.
then the hot dog class
is equal to 55.
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take
uh this training data set
and I'm going to use a map function so
what this map is doing is saying all
right whatever function is in this map
that's how we're going to we're going to
apply that to every single item in our
data set and we're going to transform
the data set that way so
buy this Lambda well this is basically
our new function Lambda means okay what
are the inputs you have an image and a
label in each data set okay so you have
this image and you have this specific
label in each data set now with that
we're going to get a new Tuple so our
new image and our new label
and that new image we're going to use
tensorflow image resizing
and we're going to pass in the original
image and then the the actual size that
we want so this would be Max side length
by Max side
life
so basically we are resizing this image
the original image into something that's
a square pixel 128 by 128 pixels
and then that's going to be the first
thing in our Tuple in our data set now
for the label what we're going to want
is actually
whether or not the label
this passed in label over here whether
or not that equals the hot dog class
right so this becomes our new data set
we're basically resizing and then our
label is just true or false zero or one
I guess true is one zero is false
um and that's just whether or not it's
equal to the hot dog class
now one other thing is that tensorflow
will complain about the the type of data
that's held in here so one thing that
we're going to have to do is tf.cast and
then we're casting this output
into
tensorflow int 32 outputs
and the same thing down here
cast we're going to cast that into
tensorflow in 32.
all right did we close all of our
parentheses
let me just double check okay yeah it
seems like we did
so then we're going to do this exact
same thing on the validation data set
so here now we're again mapping the
image into something that is a square
and then we're casting the label into
whether or not it equals a hot dog class
so let's run that cell
and now we have our training and
validation data set and let's just
verify to see if that works so let's
just show these examples again
all right now everything looks like it's
a square
and all of these say apple pie even
though it's not really apple pie and
that's just because in this data set
info it's still zero one
um but this this zero just means that it
is not a hot dog
as you can see all of these are not hot
dogs zero just apple pie is just the
default label for zero but what zero
means in our context is that it's not a
hot dog so if we actually refresh this
enough times we'll get maybe one example
with a hot dog let's see
yeah okay so I guess the default label
for one is baby back ribs so in our
specific example like apple pie means
not a hot dog and then baby back rib
means hot dog okay so essentially you'll
just see that anything that's not a hot
dog is zero and something that is a hot
dog has a label hot dog is a one
so now we have our data set in these
Square images and they're all the same
shape and then we also have our zero and
one label
okay
so one thing that we're going to have to
do is there's actually only 750 of each
food in
okay so something that we're gonna
actually have to do is rebalance our
data sets so in our training data set
there's actually only
750 hot dogs in like the entire data set
there's actually 750 of each different
category but the limiting factor here is
the hot dogs so let's try to reshape
this so that we don't have a bajillion
not hot dogs and then only a tiny little
bit of hot dogs to train on
so here
um the training hot dog size and the
validation hot dog size I'm going to set
this equal to 750 and 250. I just know
that from like the documentation of the
data set
now if I get trained hot dogs what I can
do is take this training data set put a
filter on it so whatever I don't really
care about the image
um but I'm basically filtering this by
the label being equal to one
now we can also train the not hot dogs
and this is equal to again
this image look at the label
um and the label now being zero so this
is going to significantly outweigh this
one so what I'm actually going to do is
I'm going to up sample this by just
repeating this three times
so I'm going to take that 750 and
duplicate that a few times to construct
a new data set
and I will actually do the exact same
thing for a valid validation
so our valid hot dogs
will be taking the validation data set
and running the exact same operation on
it
okay
cool
now we've split our data set into hot
dogs and then not hot dogs but the issue
is that the not hot dogs data set like
outnumbers the hot dogs they set by a
lot even though we repeated this hot dog
data set so how do we actually sample
from each one and get a balanced data
set
so that's what we're going to do here
we're going to take
we're going to create this new Training
Day set by using this function that we
need to get so in
tensorflow.data.dataset we can call the
sample from data sets function
and here we're going to pass in all the
data sets that we want to sample from so
for training that would be freeing hot
dogs and training not hot dogs
and the weights for each one so the
weights here we want 50 from here and 50
from here so I'm going to do 0.5
and 0.5
okay
and then finally we want to tell this
that once we've reached an empty data
set to stop so there's this option stop
on empty data set oops
and we're going to set this equal to
true
okay
okay so now to get this training data
set into something that we can actually
pass into our neural net what we're
going to do is we're going to Cache then
batch then prefetch and let I'll explain
that in a second so let's just type that
out first so first we're going to Cache
this
and then we're going to batch it by some
batch size which I will actually set up
here to be 16.
and then we are going to prefetch using
the parameter Auto Tune
and now I'm also going to just paste
this for validation
oops
valid
um here this should be the valid data
set
all that still applies and instead of
the train hot dogs and not hot dogs
Instead This is valid
okay
so what caching means that is that we're
going to Cache the data set somewhere so
that means we're going to save it either
in memory or local storage and that will
save some operations such as file
opening and data reading
um from being executed at the beginning
of each cycle of running the neural net
of training the neural net sorry we
batch our data set because instead of
passing just one image at a time into
the neural net we can actually pass a
bunch in and in this specific case our
batch size is 16. so in this case we're
actually passing in a whole batch of
images into the neural net so that the
neural net can train it and then using
all 16 of the images in the batch rather
than just every single image and
training on that now finally this
prefetch over here this is simply to
save more time it overlaps the time that
the pre-processing of the data is taking
place and the model execution of the
training step so basically while the
model is training step s the input
pipeline is actually already reading the
data for the next step
so this will just save us a little bit
more time
okay so now our data pipeline is ready
and what we can actually do let's run
this
all right so now just for the sake of
proving that this data is in the format
that we want it
um what I'm actually going to do is
iterate through just like the first item
in the this training data set
so I can do that by getting training
dataset.take one
and so
we can get the image batch and the label
batch
and let's print out the image batch
and let's print out the label badge
um and I need an in here for my for Loop
okay
so you'll notice that this image batch
is kind of oops useless because it's
just a bunch of tensors so there's
actually 16 images in this sensor and
the reason why I can confidently say
that is because when I go down to the
label batch somewhere down here it
actually gives us a shape 16 Vector of
the different labels in zero and one
form so here zero again means not a hot
dog one means it is a hot dog and look
at how well balanced this is there's
approximately ish like 50 50 in this
output right so that means that we have
a decently well balanced data set and
with that we can actually start the
neural network oops let's use text for
that
we can start the neural net
implementation
alrighty so I'm just first going to seed
this so that certain results are
reproducible
but we want a sequential model so I'm
going to say models dot sequential
and now this is where we're going to
start building our CNN
the first thing that I'm going to do is
I'm going to
actually rescale
the images so that we divide by 255 for
each pixel and now what that does is
instead of the scale of 0 to 255 for all
of our colors we now get zero to one
and one just means white zero means
black or like if there's color for RGB
or not now we're ready to add some
convolutional layers so here the next
thing that I want to add is layers.com
2D
and it's going to first ask for how many
different filters do we want so let's
just put 128 for that our kernel size
let's make this three by three so that's
the size of that filter that we're
moving across that image
and then let's use a relu activation
function just because it's a classic
and our input shape
so our input shape here is equal to Max
side length
Max
and then three because we have colors
all right then we want to actually add
a Max boy
player
and we'll just make that two by two
that's just pretty standard again we'll
add another convolutional layer
and now instead
here
this will just be 64.
filters we're still going to use relu
and we actually don't have to pass in
this input shape anymore
now let's add again another Max pooling
layer so actually I can just paste that
and I'm going to go with another
convolutional layer
in order to get from the convolutions to
our fully connected we actually have to
add
a flattening layer so here I'm going to
flatten that and let's just add a dense
layer so that's just a fully connected
layer
dense 128 so that means like each input
goes to every single node so 128 and
let's make the activation again for this
re-loop
and finally the output of this because
it's binary because it's either zero or
one I only need one node at the very end
that will tell us
what it is zero or one
okay so this is the general gist of what
our neural network will look like so
let's create this
and let's get started on training so our
learning rate will be 0.0001
and let's compile this model
okay so a very classic Optimizer to use
is atom and so that's what we're going
to use here you can kind of think of
this as
a tool to help us adjust the different
weights just like in the diagram that we
showed earlier to go down that gradient
towards that minimal loss
and uh our loss here will actually be
something known as binary cross entropy
so we will use
losses.binary cross entropy
and the reason the reason why we use
binary cross entropy is because we have
only a single output and we're trying to
do binary classification so whenever
it's binary classification we use binary
cross entropy
and here we have this from lagets
option
so the reason why we set from logins we
actually have to set this from log to be
true because our final layer does not
automatically project the output onto
zero to one which we would do using a
sigmoid function or something like that
so down here we have to set from log
it's to true to let our I guess loss
function know that it's not already
projected from zero to one
and finally the metrics that we want to
use to assess this might just be
accuracy
okay so let's compile the model
oops
oh okay so I'm missing an S over here
that should be accuracy Matrix equals
accuracy Okay cool so now my model is
compiled and I'm just going to set Epoch
equal to 50.
and uh we'll collect the history from
here but we're essentially going to fit
this model to the training data set the
validation
data will equal
the valid data set
epochs will equal this epochs parameter
that we pass in and then we're going to
set verbose to one so we can actually
see things get printed out so let's run
this
all right this will take a little bit of
time but you see that the accuracy
starts off not so great it started at
like 0.3 or something
okay now it's at 0.5 so the thing is we
expect just a random model to be at an
accuracy of 0.5 because we have equal
parts of the hot dogs and the not hot
dogs in the in the data set
so we do expect initially that the
accuracy would be around something like
50 percent
so our goal is to see that if we can
improve that
okay so now now our model is done
training let's go ahead and take a look
at the results
here this is each Epoch so essentially
an Epoch just means an iteration where
we go through the entire training data
set
and we see that the loss each time as we
train our model is decreasing so this
means we're getting closer and closer to
our goal of matching up our predicted
labels with the actual labels and you
can also see that reflected in the
accuracy so we start at somewhere around
50 which is expected because our data
set is comprised 50 of the hot dogs and
50 of not hot dogs so initially we would
kind of expect it to be randomized
so our accuracy at first is 50 and we
see that it increases and it actually
does fairly well after a while it gets
to an accuracy of a hundred percent
now let's see if our validation data
tells a different story so remember the
validation data is not actually data
that we pass into the training our
validation data is kind of the stated
that we set aside to evaluate how our
model is performing in the process
so
if I come over here we see that our loss
is starting to decrease so that it
actually kind of goes back up
and we also see that with our accuracy
okay it starts to go up to maybe about
and then it starts to decrease again and
it kind of stays steady and are actually
our loss also increases up to around
2.93
even though our training loss is
extremely small and our training
accuracy is a hundred percent
so what is going on here
chances are what we're doing is over
trading our model essentially what that
means is that we've passed so much data
into this model so many times that the
model has actually remembered each piece
of data and that model when it remembers
each piece of data it can actually
predict all of your trading labels 100
correctly but when it sees new data it
can't really generalize and so that's
why you see this decrease in accuracy
and loss all right so what we're going
to do is actually go back in this model
and see if we can make any changes to
make this more robust
now one thing that we can do is add
something called Dropout layers so after
each Max pooling I'm going to insert a
layer
called dropout
and I'm going to set this parameter to
0.25
what this is doing is saying at you know
just randomly during the training we're
going to turn off 25 of the connections
in between this layer sorry this layer
and this one
and so by turning off these connections
you're essentially training the model to
to be I guess susceptible to a little
bit of Randomness you're trying to train
your model so that you you know might
not have the exact same features every
time but you get the same output
so I'm going to go ahead and add this to
some of the layers
okay so now I'm going to do this before
you flatten and that's going to be my
Dropout layers
one more thing that I wanted to add to
this model before we actually ran it was
some data augmentation as well so I'm
going to insert some code up here and
call this data augmentation
so here I'm going to use
tf.karis.sequential
this is going to be our data
augmentation layer which means that when
the data when the image is passed into
the model we're actually going to
perform some operations on it so here
what I'm going to do is first pass in
a random flip
layer that will flip it along the
horizontal axis
and then I'm going to pass in
a random rotation
layer and then I'm going to pass in this
random rotation and use the factor 0.2
to randomly rotate within the range of
negative 20 times 2 pi and then positive
20 times 2 pi so basically when our
image is passed in
after it gets rescaled we can add
oops model dot add this data
augmentation layer
which will essentially perform these
operations on our input data all right
let's take a look at how this data
augmentation function actually does to
our data so I'm going to actually try to
extract the first image from our
original training data set
I'm just going to get that first image
and then let's actually show that image
oh no that's not what I wanted
I wanted to take the first one so I have
the stop take there
okay
and then let's show that image
all right cool
let's run this again let's get a more
Square image
Okay cool so we have this like Ramen
over here
so now what I want to show you is what
data augmentation does and how this is
actually being rotated
so something that I'm going to do is I'm
going to cast this to a batch so that we
can actually put it through our data
augmentation layer now what that means
is I need to expand the dimension so
essentially I just want a list where the
only thing in the list is my image
in order to do that I need to use expand
dimensions
and I'm passing in the image and I'm
just going to expand it along the very
first Dimension so that's what the zero
is it's just saying okay like put this
into an like a list holder
and I will actually cast this as well
into float 32.
and one more thing is that this
currently holds values from 0 to 255 but
when we actually show the image it's
going to expect from zero to one so I'm
just gonna right here divide this
by 255.
okay
and now we can finally show what the
figures would look like with the data
augmentation so if I create a figure
with fig size equal to 10 10 or
something
um I'm just gonna plot this with nine
rotations
and I can create an augmented image and
call my data augmentation
Pipeline on this image
and now let's just plot that so let's
define the axes for the subplot
and it'll be a size 3x3
and then I'm going to show this on the
figure so let's do the augmented image
and remember that the augmented image is
a container that holds our image so I
actually have to index into that in
order to get the image itself I'm just
going to turn off the axes
now if I run this
let's see what happens
okay so you see that we actually get
different rotations of our food and
maybe you know some flips here
but essentially it scrambles our data
set a little which is exactly what we
need in order to build robustness so
that we don't get the same input data
every single time so I'm just going to
add that as a layer right here
so let's
run this run this and so essentially
what I've done is I've added this data
augmentation to my input data and then
I've also created these layers of
Dropout that will allow us to train with
certain nodes and connections missing at
you know a given training interval all
right so one change that I'm actually
going to make from this original model
is I I'm just going to move this drop
out
down here so as far as I know when
you're building your model
they're you know General architectures
work well but there's no good answer for
where should you place these you know
layers how many nodes should you have in
these layers how many what should the
stride length be a bunch of different
questions that you know what activation
function do you use these questions are
things that are kind of almost a little
bit trial and error from what I
understand
essentially a lot of times what people
will do is simply just try to go through
and
try a bunch of combinations
based on stuff that's worked in the past
and see you know what will produce the
best outputs for you all right so one
more thing that I wanted to add to this
was actually a kernel regularizer and
what that does is just it limits how
much we can change the weights of a
given kernel so how I would do that is I
would just pass in this kernel
regularizer parameter here and I would
set this equal to
tensorflow.kara's regularizers
and let's just use an L2 so that we like
create a bigger penalty for bigger
changes
and
I will use 0.01 as my hyper parameter
here
now I'm also going to add that down here
oops
added a period over here
all right so I added this kernel
regularizer to each of these except for
this top one and just keep in mind that
the kernel regularization is meant so
that we can
the weights of the filters that we're
using in the convolutions that we're
training in the convolutions those don't
change super fast
and for the purposes of this project I'm
actually going to also decrease the
number of nodes that we have in each of
these layers just so that trains a
little bit faster
so
but these are actually parameters that
you in your free time can go and play
around with you can play around with
this parameter this where you insert the
dropouts different types of regularizers
different type of activation functions
and filter sizes Etc
so let's run so let's run this cell and
I'm going to get
um I'm going to compile the model and
then finally let's train the model down
here
okay
so now it is a waiting game and we will
just wait
okay so our model is finally done
training let's take a quick look at the
results so here we go from a training
loss of 1.6 all the way down to
something around
0.57 0.56 and we see that the accuracy
goes from 0.5 to around
like 70 percent
so 50 to 70 and this is remember on the
training set so now if we take a look at
the validation set so remember this is
the data that our model hasn't seen yet
it goes from around 1.2 and also 50
accuracy
to something around
60 validation loss or sorry 0.6
validation loss and 70 accuracy so we
have shown that we are effectively
training a model
I will say that throughout you know when
I was creating this video the best
accuracy that I could get was something
around 75 so for you guys if you go back
play with some hyper parameters the
layout of the model different
activations regularizers Etc and if you
have an accuracy that's better than 75
please do share it with everybody I
would love to learn from you
so what this means is our model can
achieve something around 70
accuracy on classification of hot dogs
versus not hot dogs on this image and
now ideally we would have also had some
sort of test data set that we could try
this model on but unfortunately our data
set did not come with that and I did not
create that so that's okay we're gonna
use our validation data set to actually
just demonstrate that this works so I'm
going to paste here the the figure that
we use in order to draw our data
augmentation images and instead of
doing this what I'm going to do is
instead use image batches from our
validation data set so image batch and
label batch
in our validation data set
take the first item remember it's a
batch already of 16.
so
the images that we want to use are this
image batch
and the labels that we want to use are
this label batch
do this but
I couldn't get it working so this will
suffice for now
and then
so let's run that
okay and then here
so in this range nine instead of an
augmented image what I'm going to do is
actually just plot the image so that we
can see what it looks like so instead
we're going to take the images and get
the ice image from that
and let's print all of these
from me looking at this clearly this is
a hot dog
I don't think that's a hot dog can't
really tell what that is hummus hot dog
garlic bread hot dog hot dog oysters and
it looks like sausage and waffle
and now if we look at our labels one
means that our model thinks it's a hot
dog zero means that it doesn't think
it's a hot dog so for the first row we
get yes no no so we get hot dog not a
hot dog not a hot dog and then we get
yes no yes so hot dog not a hot dog hot
dog and then yes no no so hot dog not a
hot dog not a hot dog
and so our model actually in these nine
images was able to classify all of them
accurately so we would literally be able
to pass this image in ask it is this a
hot dog or not and it would be able to
say yes it is which I think is pretty
awesome that concludes our introductory
course on convolutional neural Nets
thank you guys all for being here with
me today learning about the basics of
machine learning neural networks how to
train them and finally convolutional
neural networks with our hot dog or not
hot dog example I hope that you guys
learned a lot and of course post
comments Let's help each other learn and
we can all get better at ml together
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
Kylie Ying I will actually be releasing
a course on artificial intelligence
later this year so stay tuned